over the weekend in that safe city of
chicago right a five-month-old baby was
among those killed in the shootings
across the city of chicago sadly it is
just the latest case of unending
senseless insane violence across the
windy city as residents now continue to
suffer under out of control crime failed
far left rule
uh led by of course mary uh mayor laurie
lightweight she was too busy criticizing
clarence thomas this weekend
anyway here with the reaction is fox
news's own political analyst gianno
caldwell giano
i don't have words i really don't except
my heart aches for you
i
i can't imagine how you feel today like
yesterday when you got that call
and what's so frustrating and even
angering to me is it's been going on for
decades and nobody lifts a finger to
stop it
how you you know how do you react to
that
well sean i come here tonight is it
a man who feels shattered my baby
brother christian who just turned 18
this year is no longer with me
he
he was a good kid and certainly knowing
that living in chicago seemingly comes
with a price these days
but i would never have intended or
rather expect it that it would come with
a death sentence for my baby brother
black bodies are being littered in the
streets of chicago and it's not just
impacting african americans here it's
impacting everyone you can't go downtown
chicago now without looking around your
shoulder you may be shot there the truth
of the matter is we need to uncuff the
police and that's what's happened the
the policies the cell phone crime
policies that have been pushed by many
of the elected officials here are only
causing more crime they've only beared
dead fruit and now my family is paying
the price
your family's paying the price i know
you read about the five-month-old the
five-month-old baby like
five months old but that's not that's
not just the five month year old you got
kids that are five years old that are
dying here
you cannot prevent crime in this city
unless you get tough
and the city has decided not to get
tough now with the with mary and larry
lightfoot i hope that she'll have the
the police department make this case my
little brother christian a priority i'm
hoping for it i'm hoping that the county
prosecutor will make this a priority i'm
hoping that these four men who got out
of a black suv on friday while my little
brother was standing in front of a venue
just a few blocks from his house and
riddled the area with bullets i'm hoping
that these men are captured they were
four african-american men with dreads is
what i'm told i'm hoping that this
interview will spark someone who may be
in the area who might have seen
something to call the police and say hey
we got a tip for you we need this solved
and i need it solved immediately my
family has been through so much growing
up on the south side of chicago
extremely poor mom consumed by drugs and
haven't had this happen
this year when my little brother was
considering which college he was going
to go to that was what he was thinking
about what school was he going to attend
and now he doesn't even have that option
he will never get married he will never
see his first child he will never have a
real career
and i don't blame myself for it
because i did everything i can do with
the family and ensuring that everything
works out well he didn't do anything
wrong but at the same time the fact that
they're still in chicago in this in
these areas where crime is being
people are murdered in the street
bothers me and it hurts me and now i got
to think about solutions and what can i
do to ensure that my baby brother's life
meant something
you know giano
my heart just
aches for you and and obviously your
heart is broken
the sad reality is on this show since
2009 i'd scroll the names of all the
people shot
all the people shot and killed
and it's and this is this isn't
political for me because every life is
from god and matters to me
and
nobody ever seems to care unless unless
there's some political component to it
yeah uh this isn't political you can't
if you don't have law and order if you
don't have safety and security you can't
uh pursue happiness and your dreams your
god-given talents i believe that you're
that your brother had
um that this five-month-old had
um please know that every i know i speak
for everybody at fox where you're in our
prayers
we ache for you we're praying for you
praying for your whole family praying
for your brother and praying more
importantly that this stops we know how
to do good policing if we want to do it
new york went from nearly 3 000 murders
a year down to 300 aggressive policing
worked there are things we can do to
protect people
um absolutely needed here and i want to
thank from the bottom of my heart my fox
news family you all have been amazing
suzanne scott you sean everyone in in
the fox news channel has ensured that
this was made a national story and
certainly have shined light in a way
that no one had could have ever
anticipated but it should not be that i
should be a member of the fox news
family and get get coverage for this and
see possible change it shouldn't be what
about the people that live in chicago
that has no one who doesn't have a
brother who may be on national
television who may not have a father
who's a politician or someone who's
perceived important that should never be
the case last year alone was the highest
murder rate in the quarter of a century
here in chicago you got murderers who
are at home right now people are waiting
for trial with with monitoring devices
on why aren't they in jail why aren't
these people being prosecuted the the
clearance rate is low what's going on
here in the city of chicago and i'm
telling you i just want justice for my
little brother christian that's all i
want so if anyone is listening and you
know anything if you don't want to reach
out to the police dm me on instagram
giano caldwell reach out to me on
facebook do whatever we just want to see
an end to this senseless violence
because it continues and if the soft on
crime policy continues then no one no
one can ever be safe in the city of
chicago you know this defund dismantled
no bail laws we
now have last year was a record and
we're on track for another record in
terms of murder rates in many big cities
gianna we love you uncuffed the police
uncuff the police that's what's next we
fund them they refund them doing their
job now and they they're demoralized
they're
in this city and they're demoralizing
another a lot of other major cities we
have to support law enforcement there is
a balance between police reform criminal
justice reform we need to make sure that
people feel safe and that the police are
operating in a proper way as they should
but we have to uncuff the police and let
them do their damn job sean
i can't say it any better gianna we love
you at fox we're in our i love you guys
back whatever you want to do for you
we'll be here hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else